hi there today we'll look at spine net
learning scale per muted backbone for
recognition and localization by yawns
adieu at all of Google research on a
high level this paper proposes to take
current recognition and localization
networks which have a CNN backbone
usually something like a res net and
switch up the order of the blocks in the
res net and cross connect them in a
different way such that they reach a
higher accuracy with the new network
that has the same amount of parameters
or almost the same amount of parameters
they then further modify this network
such that it reaches that higher
accuracy with less compute than the
original network so if you want to know
how it's done you know stick around you
can help me by sharing out this video if
you liked it if you didn't like it leave
a comment and tell me what you didn't
like otherwise I have no chance of
improving so that's the deal
ok cool so the task here is a
recognition and localization as you can
see here which basically means that you
have an image and there's stuff on the
image
maybe there's a cat right here and maybe
there is some kind of a house right here
and the task these tasks come in various
forms but some of the tasks are to say
what's on the image so in this case cat
and house and also where is it now this
could be a point this could be a
bounding box or this could actually be a
pixel segmentation all of this sort of
tasks exists in various forms what
usually is done in these tasks is you
want to go in some way through a neural
network and the neural network will
output the same image again or the same
shape so it will output a image that is
of the same shape that if this is your
input image I'm gonna I'm just gonna
quickly redraw without the labels if
this is your input image then the output
image let's say we're doing bounding
boxes the output would say something
like
here are bounding boxes and also the
output would be cat and house so these
are the two outputs that the neural
network would generate this is some sort
of a convolutional neural network
because they deal with images fairly
well now usually when we do image
processing and we know this from for
example image classification so if we
just have image classification just to
classify here if we just want the
outputs cat or house or even just one
single thing like an image net our
convolutional neural networks have a
particular architecture namely what we
do is we have the first convolutional
neural net the cut through first layers
will take the image and run these
convolutional filters across them which
gives you the same shape image back but
then with time we scale it down we have
a max pooling or a convolution with
stripe to so that the image is only this
big anymore and then we have a bunch of
further layers and then we scale it down
again and so on now as we scale it down
the number of channels goes up of course
at the beginning you have three channels
for the three colors but then after the
first convolution you might have
whatever 32 channels right here this is
no longer the original image this now is
of course for each pixel you have a
stack of features right you have a stack
of features right here because that's
what your convolutional layer does and
then when you scale it down you have
even more feature Maps so we tend to
scale down the resolution of our feature
maps but we tend to increase the number
of feature Maps right here the reasoning
behind this is if you look at these
bounding boxes they they don't really so
not enough sorry if you look at the
labels right here the fact that there's
a cat on the image shouldn't depend on
the exact pixel location of the cat
right so even if I scale this down a bit
I'll still recognize that there's a cat
somewhere it can still a great
that information in fact I could deal
with a single right I could deal with
scaling this down successively up to a
single pixel and that's ultimately what
an image classifier does you simply have
a single vector at the end with the
features in it and from that you
classify so the reasoning is that as you
go through the network you pick up the
low-level features first like here you
pick up the edges and the kind of
low-level shapes as you go higher
through the network your features become
more abstract but less localized which
means that it's less important where
they are and that's why you look at this
image through a coarser and coarser
segmentation and at the end you your
segmentation might be something like
this okay so we we have had a lot of
success building image classifiers with
this reasoning and this is sort of a
human heuristic that just hasn't worked
well now when we do something like this
bounding box classification or even per
pixel classification all of a sudden it
is very important where the things are
right it is very important that it's
this pixel and this pixel on this pixel
and this pixel forming the bounding box
because the more accurate you are the
better your bounding box classifier you
still have this right here this
recognition but the localization part we
can't just scale down anymore because we
need to output something that's of the
same size so what people have done is
they've gone from this kind of from
architecture that scales down because we
know that works well we know the down
scaling works well so we take that and
then we scale up again and there is some
reasoning behind this right so that's
what we can do because we know this part
works were very well for extracting
high-level features that are not that
localized so our reasoning is going to
be something like okay we'll force the
network through this kind of bottleneck
right here it will force it to learn
some high-level features we because
otherwise you can just you know kind of
remember the individual pixels and that
won't work
as well we'll force it to remember the
high level will force it to remember
what a cat is and then it will help in
the pixel segmentation to know what a
cat is
this is very valid assumption but it
doesn't need to be the case and so there
is one additional thing that these
networks usually do is that they have
like some skip connections here from the
layers that are of the same size to the
layers that are of the same size right
here to here in order to kind of recover
these high level features because if you
only look at an image through the lens
of this right here and you're you have
to segment the ear of the cat you know
you can only either color an entire
pixel or not
so you want to gain back some of that
some of those high-level features and
that's what you do with skip connections
and that's why these networks usually
look like this now in this work the
authors
sort of criticize this they say why why
are we doing it like this isn't there a
better way to do it specifically we want
to look at this part right here which is
called the backbone so we assume that we
have these these output layers that give
you at different scales different
features and what we have to do is we
have to construct a backbone that
somehow feeds features either you know
through this direct way or through these
connections right here and feeds
features to this these ultimate
classifiers so these classifiers will
then be used to classify the bounding
boxes and classify the output classes
for recognition and localization this is
an illustration of this on the left you
see a typical backbone and they call
this a scale decreased network so an
example of scale decreased network on
the Left versus a scale per mutant
network on the right the width of the
block indicates feature resolution and
the height indicates feature dimension
dotted arrows represent connections from
two blocks not plotted okay so on the
left you have the typical architecture
you see that the the
with that this is the resolution is very
high and as you go through the layers
that resolution gets smaller and smaller
and smaller but the number of features
indicated by the height gets higher and
higher and higher as you go through this
is your typical architecture we are
looking into let's say that this is not
the only one what we can do is we can
build any sort of backbone and here they
restrict themselves they say ok in order
to make it comparable in order to be you
know a scientifically a bit more
rigorous than just building anything
what we restrict ourselves are simply
permutations of this so we only allow us
to permute these things so all the you
know this goes here and this goes here
as you see and that ensures that you
still have roughly the same amount of
parameters now there is a sort of a
parameter difference because these
connections here you need to up and down
sample the images and sometimes that
introduces parameters but in essence you
have the rough same amount of parameters
and then you can really research what
can we improve a network simply by
rearranging its blocks because that
would give evidence that's this scaling
down architecture isn't really the best
one ok so here you can see an example of
this this is what they call a scale per
muted Network sorry this scale per muted
network right here so in a scale per
muted network what you're allowed to do
is you're allowed you have these blocks
on the left and you're allowed to put
them anywhere you want in in any in any
sort of yep I don't want to say order
but yes in any sort of order
yes it's an order actually so it goes
from here down it this is one two three
four five any block for any block you
first place a first place this block
you're allowed to connect it to any
other block before it now here we don't
see but you can see there's two incoming
connections right here so we make use of
more than one connection on the left you
see there's always
one connection between the blocks and on
the right you see we allow up to two
blocks to connect to a given block okay
then you are done with this block you
place the next block this one here also
you're allowed to have two incoming
connections this one here and this one
here and you place the next block and so
on now how you make this you you also
see that there doesn't need to be like a
straight linear path because there is no
connection right here if you can see
that so you might be wondering how do I
decide which block goes where and how do
I decide on which connections connect
where and that is going to be the the
idea here to use neural architecture
search so neural architecture search
right now it's still a fancy way of
saying let's try stuff out and so what
you'll do is you will initialize a
reinforcement learning controller that
decides on the ordering end on the
connections and it has some action space
and you basically let it run so it it
you know proposes a couple of
architectures and and then you measure
all of them you train all of these
architectures and you see how well they
fare and then you go back to the
controller that's the reward signal and
so we can draw so you have an agent
which builds the building plans so the
agent in the agent will emit as an
action a building plan like big small
big small big with connections like this
and like this and like this and then
that will go to the environment the
environment here simply takes the
architecture and trains train the
architecture and then the let's say the
ivalice or the validation laws the
validation accuracy is equal is going to
be your reward signal so you simply
train a reinforcement learning agent to
solve this particular problem which is
training this in recognizer
localization on the particular data set
as well as possible to basically come up
with the best architecture which you
know it's it's fancy and it's a bit
better than trying everything out but
it's not much better right now and it
takes a lot of compute to run these
experiments because it takes a lot of
iterations of this and every iteration
consists of training one of these
networks fully once now you can do
something with like early stopping and
stuff but so you get the idea this is
what they what they propose and this is
you know how they get better so there
are a number of challenges in this
namely we've we said okay when you input
a signal for example when you input a
signal from this layer to this layer you
can see that you have to shrink the
resolution and you have to up the number
of features and this was already sort of
solved in the resinate original resonate
paper but they reiterate how they do
this here basically you have we have
this layer and it is connected to these
two layers we said every layer can
receive inputs from two layers you see
at the very end these are just added
together okay so we have two things
first of all the number of features is
different you can see right over here
the number of features the number of
channels is different than the number of
channels in the output image let's say
right here so those are different and in
fact they're different in both inputs
and we have this method of one-by-one
convolutions that was introduced in the
original resonate paper if we do
one-by-one convolutions it's basically a
a learned transformation from a number
of input channels to a number of output
channels without change without doing
any actual convolution operation this is
simply a linear operation up scaling or
up up up being the number of feature
Maps you can see these one
by one convolutions are employed here in
various ways so because this is fairly
compute-intensive or so they claim what
they do first is they always first go to
less features so here we have a number
of features which is maybe let's say
this is F or sorry this is c0 you can
see very small here maybe that there is
this first we go to alpha times C 0 and
alpha is I think in the default setting
it's 1/2 so first we always go to 1/2
the number of features before we do this
switch here and then we have two options
either so you go to 1/2 the features and
at the end you go to the number of
target features so it could be if the
target features are more than you
currently have it could be that you
first go to less features and then you
go to even more features right as if you
the current one has more features than
the end it's probably not as bad because
you first go to less features and into
even less features this is probably one
of the things they did to save
computation
but which you can imagine that it hurts
because here you simply have to you have
to basically throw away half the
features or you have to like linearly
combine them in every step where you
connect two layers to each other you
know okay so there's two situations
first situation your current resolution
here is higher than the target
resolution in that case we can simply do
a convolution with a bigger stride than
one right if you have an image and you
do a convolution usually you have this
overlapping convolution such that the
result is the same size as you started
with but you can also do a bigger stride
and I'm bit over drawing this here but
you can do a bigger stride such that the
final resolution is smaller and you can
also do this max pooling right here so
the max pooling is
also a way to reduce the number of of
the resolution of the image so if we're
bigger we can do that if we are
currently smaller than the target what
we can do is we can up sample and up
sample you can do by doing nearest
neighbor or things like this we can also
do a learned up sample there are various
ways I believe here they do a nearest
neighbor but I'm not sure anymore
actually let's check it out that's here
somewhere resampling in cross-scale
connections yada yada yada yada yada
yada yada is important to keep the
computational recent and low we
introduced a scaling factor alpha we had
that then we use a nearest neighbor
interpolation for up sampling or a
stripe to 3x3 convolution okay so it's
nearest neighbor by up sampling all
right so that's that's how they up and
down sample the feature Maps to the
correct shapes either using nearest
neighbor up sampling or using multi
stride convolution followed by max
pooling so what does that give them now
they do several different steps in this
so the first architecture this ResNet 50
is the original architecture and
remember we're only talking about the
backbone right here now in the original
ResNet 50 architecture we have this
resin at 50 fps and this fpn is these
are the called the output layers this is
what then goes and classifies the
bounding boxes and the labels and so on
now here you can see the resin at 50 is
continuously getting smaller and more
features they do an intermediate step so
this this right here is their final
thing where they let this let this
algorithm go wild and you can see that
it's pretty
pretty fuzzy so this RL controller finds
this architecture to be the best
architecture and you can see it's
continuously down and up and down and
sorry and up and down and there is
considerable cross connections between
all of these things and then here you
have the you have two different output
layers built into the network rather
than next to the network right so these
are the ones that are now the red border
ones are now the features that are used
for going and classifying as an
intermediate step they also consider
this architecture where they basically
built a smaller ResNet right here and
then let the algorithm decide on the
rest right here so it still has the same
amount of parameters roughly but they
can investigate what happens if we go to
these to this lower if we have this
structure at the beginning but then part
of it we can do with our algorithm and
lastly they also consider this
architecture now this architecture again
their algorithm has control over the
whole network but there is an additional
thing that the algorithm can do the
algorithm can also decide to change the
number of features and to change the
type of block so here you can see these
are all residual blocks and these are
these called bottleneck blocks they're
simply a different way of doing a
residual block it wasn't introduced in
the original ResNet paper but the the
controller can simply switch to that and
that can save some computation if you go
through these bottleneck blocks so what
does that give you you can see below
that the reson at 50 is at thirty seven
point eight percent average precision if
you liberate the top part to leave it to
the algorithm it's at 39 if you liberate
the entire network it's at forty point
seven and remember these are like
roughly the same amount of parameters
and then if you if you also let the
network control a bit of the features
sighs and the type of block you get a 40
point eight which is the same as before
but now this one I believe has about oh
yeah here we go
with ten percent fewer flops okay so
that's that's pretty cool
though remember that the left thing this
is this is made by humans this is just
our heuristic and the right things they
are made by RL and they are you know for
these particular datasets though they do
find that generally this also transfers
to image net classification but still
this is sort of a it works well for the
type of data we work with and so on so I
don't know how much I would trust it how
far we should go of building spine net
49 as our new backbone for every image
task that we have it remains to be seen
I believe before actually we go to the
experiments before we go to the
experiment I want to state my idea right
here so you get the general gist here
and so another kind of quarrel I have
with this is that you know in here you
always have these single connections and
here you always have these these double
connections and I've looked through the
experiment it seems like no where do
they ablate or anything what what it
means to only have single connections or
if they so if they let the ResNet run
with double connections so if their
controller could not switch the order
but only introduced the connections they
might have done this they have a lot of
experiments where they do the different
ablations so I would be interested what
happens when you let it run on the res
net but let it have two connections per
per layer is it then better or not so
here the importance I'll get you my idea
later the importance of scale
permutation that's where they
investigate how important is
that you permute the layers and that
turns out to be fairly important then
the importance of cross-scale
connections that's how they investigate
here so these are these connections they
say the cross-scale connections play a
crucial role in fusing features at
different resolutions throughout the
scale per mutant network so that's the
reasoning behind it we we take features
from different kind of resolutions and
we can also scale up again and then
scale down again to gain some additional
features from the from the higher
resolutions we study it's important by
graph damage so either they remove the
short term connections or they remove
the long range connections or they
remove both and then connect one block
to the previous block via a sequential
connection so this is only this is only
in the things that they learned right so
this model is where they fully give
their model control over the ordering
and connections you can see that as this
40.7%
now if they delete the short-range
connections they drop 235 if they delete
the only the long-range they drop two
even more so here you can see that these
long-range connections which I guess are
connections that are going across and
you have multiple blocks skipping
multiple blocks these tend to be very
important so you can make the case that
it might be very important to fuse these
things from different layers to free use
the features from different resolutions
because these long range connections
tend to be important though it's one
thing to say that if we just leave them
away with our model if we just damage it
and then let it run it it it drops in
accuracy it's not entirely the same
thing as to say that these are important
because you don't really know what
happens like if you train without them
maybe you could if you train without
them you could reach as good and
accuracy so this graph damage
investigation it has something but not I
wouldn't trust it too much and
yeah I think they haven't investigated
what happens if they keep the ResNet
order but let the connections be twice
but you get the general the general idea
of the paper right here of what they do
now they do this with architecture
search right here but here's an idea
okay I propose the following you have an
image right here and we are wondering
here
should we let it go through a layer
that's wide and with less features
that's you know very many features but
not as wide but we have to downscale the
image or should we let it go first
through something intermediate let's see
it like this
okay so we're wondering how should we
order these blocks why can we do all of
at the same time why can't we do this
this and this okay and then in the next
layer again do all of them at the same
time and you you you can already see
where this is going I hope I hope you
can see where this is going so you have
a routing right here and how do we do
routing in modern times in deep learning
with attention so I propose you have
layers with different attention let's
say these are these are now your your
sequences or you can also make them as
attention heads okay these are your
these and the lower level features are
routed to the higher level features with
an attention mechanism and you do this
layer by layer by layer so you let
because what's the problem here the
problem here is that the same data point
has to go you know you find these good
connections but the all the data points
have to go through the same connections
and it might actually be that you need
different routing depending on the data
point it might be that what this is this
is going
for the average data point but it will
be much better if whenever there's a cat
you take one path and whenever there's a
dog you take a different path so this
will allow for that you basically have
the routing parameterize by an attention
mechanism this I have no clue how much
compute this would take it doesn't seem
that outrageous because what's your
sequence length here your sequence
length is going to be the number of
layers maybe and maybe times the number
of feature maps maybe have different
attention head so you maybe want to
replicate some of those here but
ultimately I would guess the attention
mechanism itself isn't that much of an
overhead maybe it's an overhead that you
have so many in parallel yeah but you
know it remains to be seen that's that's
the idea yeah you heard it here first
okay so they have more experiment so
they also build here is where they say
okay we have two spine net 49 now and we
found this to work we found this to work
really well this is our spine net 49
architecture oh and we want to make it
bigger but I guess they didn't have the
computational resources to run the
neural architecture search for bigger
networks this is now as about as big as
a resin at 50 right but what if you were
to go to a resonant 100 or a resonant
150 there you you don't have the
computational resources do neural
architecture
imagine this google has it doesn't have
the computational resources to do neural
architecture search on this thing so
this must be expensive or I'm just I
have no idea but what they do is they
kind of do a trick so here they take the
the spine net 49 and they say we build a
spine net 60 to 96 by simply repeating
each block twice so all the incoming
connections would go to the first block
and all the outgoing connections would
come from the second block right here
you had to in and maybe there's actually
no limit to how many outgoing
connections you can have and also you
can also do this three times which
I think is a bit of a cheap way and it
kind of defeats the entire purpose right
couldn't you make the exact same
argument again here that maybe it's
helpful to route from this block right
here or maybe it's helpful that these
don't have the same scale right after
one another
it just seems but okay so they say we
found this good structure and we simply
duplicate each block I'm not that big of
a fan in any case so they train this and
it of course outperforms everything else
if you compare with kind of models of
the same size so here you compare this
spine net 49 to the res net 50 and you
can see there's about the same number of
parameters how about it outperforms the
resonant 50 very much and as you go up
the number of parameters here the
performance goes up yet again and I
believe these dagger ones here are
simply trained with a special schedule
with here with applying stochastic depth
and swish activation for a longer
training schedule so you can see that
not only do you are the spine nets sorry
of the number of parameters is here not
only are the spine nets slightly smaller
than the res nets they do require less
flops and they reach better accuracy so
you know every everything is a win here
yeah so they apply this to these data
sets I don't want to go you know too
much into into that but in the last part
they also apply this to image net so
there's image classification where they
basically say okay we can just go to our
architecture and we can just add up all
the output blocks we scale them
appropriately and add up all the output
blocks right here because these are good
features for localization and so on and
we can train it to do image
classification so
all of these go into a big combination
classifier that does the 1,000 classes
of image net image classification and
that also works pretty well with this
network so they basically argue what
they found is sort of a better image
image processing network than the
resonate 50 and I guess they would argue
that from now on you should take this as
your backbone for image classification
and recognition and so on which it's
entirely possible that this works better
there's no particular reason why the
resonate 50 should work at all right
it's just a heuristic but I guess the I
it remains to be to be seen whether
that's generally true or just in the
things they considered so you can see
right here the spine net generally
improving over the image net which is
not stated right here but it does
generally improve and you can see as you
go higher and higher spine net the the
numbers tend to improve as well and this
is already pretty respectable
respectable number for image net right
all right so this was it for this paper
for this particular paper they do have
you know two different of these object
detection recognition datasets and I
invite you to check out the experiments
more closely if you're interested in
that sort of thing I was mainly
interested in the method of doing and
arranging these layers and so on it
seems like it's a cool engineering
project cool investigative project the
experiments are done well and in the end
they reach a better you know they
achieve they get a better model out of
that and if it turns out that this model
is a good model the entire community
will be better off unfortunately there's
no broader impact statement to tell us
that also the terrorists will be able to
use this for purposes but you can
imagine
that yourself alright that was it for me
again leave a comment if you want me to
change anything or have suggestions
leave a like if you liked the video
share it out bye bye